along side the cells that make up our
bodies there are trillions of
microscopic organisms it's not just the
friendly bacteria in our guts that help
us digest food bacteria live on our skin
in our mouths and in the vagina and it's
not just bacteria we're home to
populations of viruses fungi and archaea
too when does this colonization begin
most scientists think we acquire our
first bacteria when we're born and
before that babies develop in a sterile
environment but recently a few studies
have found traces of bacterial DNA in
the placenta and in the amniotic fluid
that surrounds the fetus as well as in
meconium a baby's first poo could this
be evidence of bacteria living with us
before birth
maybe but many scientists think these
findings could be the result of
contamination there's an ongoing debate
whatever the answer everyone agrees that
the first major colonization occurs drin
and just after birth babies born by
vaginal delivery get a dose of bacteria
from their mothers as they pass through
the birth canal after birth the baby
acquires more microbes from the air and
from contact with objects and people
around her as she grows many factors
influence the makeup of her microbiota
her diet whether or not she takes
antibiotics or other drugs how many
people she interacts with whether she
has pets where she lives and potentially
also her genetic makeup children that
live in rural areas surrounded by
animals and dirt hosts different sets of
microbes - children brought up in urban
environments if children aren't exposed
to a wide variety of microbes they seem
to be more likely to develop autoimmune
and allergic conditions such as asthma
and eczema this is known as the hygiene
hypothesis and it's one example of how
our microbiota influences our health
throughout our lives by adulthood our
bodies contain as many microscopic
Albanese
as human cells if not more our
physiology relies on these communities
for example they protect us from harmful
bacteria and help us digest food as
microbes break down food they produce
molecules called metabolites which
circulate in the bloodstream reaching
all tissues of the body and affecting
our metabolism a diverse community of
gut microbes contributes to a healthy
metabolism a less diverse microbiota is
associated with inflammatory bowel
disease obesity and type 2 diabetes some
studies even suggest that microbial
metabolites can affect the brain and
influence our mental health as we get
older our microbiota continues to change
studies show that the gut microbiota of
older people differs from that of young
adults potentially contributing to aging
related changes to our immune system and
brain function there's an awful lot
still to learn about how the many
microorganisms that live with us
contribute to our well-being and
influence our health we need a better
understanding of why microbes differ
between people and how these differences
affect our biology and in particular we
need more studies of microbiomes
in non-white populations and from all
regions of the world what is clear is
that without these microbes we wouldn't
be here
you